worthy rival there's another guy who
does what I do
he gives talks he writes books he's
extremely well respected he does very
good work I like and respect his work as
well I just happened to hate him it's
nothing personal
he's always been very kind and
respectful to me whenever I've seen him
at engagements and yet I irrationally
hate him and because of my hatred for
him I am very competitive with him and I
will regularly go online and check my
book rankings and then immediately go
and check his mind you I don't check
anyone elses just his and if I'm a head
I'm smug and if I'm behind I'm angry we
had the opportunity to speak at the same
event together and I don't mean me in
the morning and him in the afternoon I
mean we were interviewed together on the
same stage at the same time and the
interviewer thought it would be fun if
we introduced each other and so I went
first and I turned him and I said you
make me incredibly insecure all of your
strengths are all of my weaknesses and
whenever your name comes up I get
extremely uncomfortable and he turned to
me he said funny I feel the same about
you
it turns out the reason I hated him so
much had nothing to do with him and had
everything to do with me it's because
his strengths revealed to me my
weaknesses and that made me feel
insecure and it was easier to channel
all of that energy against him it was
easier to channel all that energy into
trying to beat him in order to make
myself feel better rather than to take a
hard look at myself and say I've got
some work to do the funny thing is is
that was such a cathartic experience for
both of us that we've actually become
very close friends and now we work
together on a regular basis because it
turns out people can buy more than one
book
and it turns out that even easier than
working on my weaknesses is simply to
partner with somebody whose strengths
are my weaknesses advice versa in other
words you have to have worthy rivals
when we have competitors in business we
adopt this mindset of needing to win or
needing to beat them the problem is this
is not a finite game there's no such
thing as winning because we haven't
agreed upon any metrics we haven't
agreed upon any time frames you get to
choose the metrics that you've declared
that you're the winner you're ahead it's
totally arbitrary is it based on
revenues market share is it based on who
has more followers on Twitter no no it
should really based be based on whom and
who has more followers on Instagram like
we get to choose the in other words the
whole thing is ridiculous a worthy rival
is another player in the game
that is worthy of comparison that in
some way shape or form reveals to you
weaknesses that you have that are
opportunities for you to work to improve
yourself you get to pick your own worthy
rivals you can have many of them they
can be entire companies they can be
individuals they don't even have to be
in your industry but there are people
that you respect you don't have to like
them but you respect that they are
better at things than you are and it
shows you where your opportunities to
improve are and remember in the infinite
game the only true competitor is
yourself
and if the game of an infinite mindset
is playing with an infinite mindset is a
game of constant improvement what better
way to discover your weaknesses then
from those who are better than us at so
many things
respect your worthy rivals and adapt as
they fall out of the game in the early
days of the PC apples worthy rival was
IBM Apple were the Pirates and IBM
represented the Navy Apple represented
the rebels and IBM represented the
status quo that they were fighting
against but then IBM fell out of the
game that didn't mean Apple had won it
simply mean that the other player had
fallen out of the game and so they were
replaced by Microsoft Apple now
represented the Pirates and Microsoft
represented the Navy remember hi I'm a
Mac I'm a PC was this us against them
and then Microsoft was no longer a
worthy rival and now it's Google and
Facebook and company
like that and the fight is no longer
about necessarily personal computing or
the status quo but it now it seems to be
about personal privacy and still Apple
seems to be representing the individuals
concerns more than the corporates
concerns in other words they're just
cause is still alive and well
it's just operating in a different way
and they use their worthy rivals to not
only reveal their weaknesses but to keep
them on the straight and narrow who
you're worthy rivals
[Music]